(all exclaiming)
Oh no!
I'm sorry Wren!
I'm so sorry Wren!
So today we're gonna play "Archery Golf".
It's like frisbee golf exept
instead of there being a basket or a pole
that you have to hit with a frisbee,
It's a person
that you have to hit with an arrow!
Now, whoever has to take the most shots to hit that person
becomes the flag pole for the next round.
You will get hit with an arrow.
Wren, you remeber when I said I needed you to be
an integral part of this video?
Of course...
Oh, that's what you meant!
I need you to put on the Waldo shirt and be the first target.
So let me get this straight...
You're all gonna take turns shooting an arrow at me?
Yes.
Whoever takes the most shots to get to you
becomes the target for the second round.
Oh man I hope Jake does poorly.
Too bad I'm super good at archery!
Go down there
Bye Wren!
Bye Obey!
Uh, how do you wanna determine who goes first?
Chin-Chin!
Niko, let us begin Chin-Chin.
Chin-Chin two!
Chin-Chin none!
Chin-Chin three!
Fuck!
Yes!
Whoo!
Here you go Jake
Alright
There's a little kid out there though so...
He'll be fine
I'm not even gonna put the mask on for this cause they're so far away
Didn't even make it halfway...
That was disappointing...
Now we got Niko firing it
Woah, that did pretty good
Thank you
That was pretty good!
I wonder if they know that they have to shoot the arrow
at a 45° angle to maximize the distance
That's physics.
That was weaksauce
Brett, you are away so please, begin!
I hope they don't hit Obey
my wife would not be happy
He missed
but he actually came pretty close!
The striped shirt kinda threw me off a little bit
Nice shot!
Blows the birdie opportunity!
Can I, can I just knock it in real quick?
Yeah, go ahead go ahead
(laughs)
Yes
Nine iron huh? Well, you're fired
This is for par baby!
Aagghh
Whooo!
Alright! Everyone is on par!
I think we tied
Yeah that's a Chin-Chin game
Alright it's a Chin-Chin game to see
who, uh
Is the unfortunate victim
Here's how the game of Chin-Chin works
If you watch this now you must play Chin-Chin for life
Just like in rock-paper-scissors where there's a rhythm
where you go: "one, two, three, shoot!"
It's the same for Chin-Chin
"Chin-Chin-blank"
On that beat you say a number
I'm gonna go with: "Chin-Chin three!"
And everyone gets to decide to put up either thumbs,
both thumbs,
or no thumbs.
And if I say a number that is equal to the number
of thumbs that popped up,
I lose one hand!
And the first one to lose both hands wins
So you keep going until there's one loser
Chin-Chin six!
Chin-Chin two
Chin-Chin two!
Alright Chin-Chin two!
Chin-Chin three!
Chin-Chin none!
Chin-Chin one
Chin-Chin two!
Chin-Chin one!
Whoo!
Alright...
What does "par" mean?
A par is how many shots it should take you to get into the target/hole
It should take a competent archer four shots to get to Brett
and hit him.
I'm not gonna lose this game
Right through that hole in the trees
Oh, bold strategy!
And it looks like it's payed off!
He's almost there in a birdie, my god
Oh, no!
That's like when you're trying to
go between the sand trap and the pond
then you hit the sand trap
Alright Wren
Is your go-pro rolling?
Woah, woah
Was everything rolling?
Awww...
Ooh that's in the pond!
That's in the pond baby!
I hadn't fired the arrow yet!
You just fired it!
Wren CLEARLY hit the pond
Wren you're gonna have to take a drop buddy
Put it behind you and then drop it
then wherever it lands is where you shoot from
Alright, further back it is!
Further back! (laughs)
I might be able to shoot it out of the tree...
I think I can do it!
Hold on. Real quick, real quick
Ready?
NOOO!
I told you we were gonna lose another one!
You're gonna have to bear-hug it all the way up
This is a bad idea
Yeah...
Brett is just standing out in the field waiting for us to shoot at him
You've lost two precious irons
To the tree of death!
Let us move on!
Ready Brett?
Oh! Aww
(laughs)
This is what a good shot looks like
Sorry Brett
Oh that was a par!!!
Wren, you're away, sir
Oh, triple bogie!
Triple bogie
"Wren Whiteman, for triple bogie"
OHH
Wren is tilting right now
Wooo
Oh he hit him, he hit him
that counts
Barely!
We're all sportsmen here
what do we do when somebody hits the target?
Well Wren
Unfortunately for you
and fortunately for me, Niko and Brett
You're now the flagpole again
fantastic...
So we're gonna raise the stakes a little bit
the flagpole will be on the other side of the water
I have a feeling both Brett and Jake are gonna
put and arrow into the water
What's up Jake?
How about we do a tactical skill shot
where you have to shoot it to the edge
and then shoot across
No we're gonna lose our arrows, guaranteed
Come on dude...
None of you guys have the control to not overshoot
I'll bet you!
I'll bet you ten dollars!
I won't overshoot it
Um, I just saw you overshoot it five minutes ago
Yeah, I know. But I be you on this one I won't
I bet you ten dollars.
Ten dollars?
This is like the handshake between
Trudeau and Donald Trump
Wait a minute...
Oh you mean like this?
Yeah, yeah like (struggles)
Haha like, what was that?
We're gonna start back there...
wait for him to get to the edge here
and then shoot over the water.
SKILL is the name of this game
And I'm gonna make ten bucks in the process
What's the par?
Par...
Three?
Par three
Confidence level is high...
I plan on just taking a little bit of Niko's pride with this one
I could maybe aim for one of those trees
just hit the tree and it'll stop it right there
but if I miss the tree it goes right into the water.
Or I could shoot it up
so it comes back down with no forward momentum
and then hits the ground in front
More than anything else I don't want it to go into the water
So that Jake can't gloat
He takes no risks
Niko "safety"  Pueringer
This arrow here is worth ten dollars to Niko
My pride is worth ten dollars
All about to change...
(all exclaiming)
It's right here!
We're safe!
Good show, good show
Niko are you gonna go over?
Yes, yes I will be
Don't lose it in the water!
No chance
Ready?
It's in the water!
Oh... More over! Wow...
That added way more clearance than I thought I needed
Well Niko...
You've earned ten dollars, Jake
Where is it?
Oh I don't have any cash on me
I'll Venmo him ten dollars
You better Venmo me...
Full draw, full draw, full draw there you go!
Whoo, clips the tree on the way over!
Oh, you guys are so close!
That was great
Fortunately, I made it across the pond
but, I'm right in front of this tree.
Do I shoot over the next branch and under the one after that?
Or do I attempt to go over this one, and over that one
and then under the white tree?
I would go over this and then under this...
Well Niko, that's where you and I are different
Cause I'm gonna go over both
Ready?
Oooh, very close
Whoo!
I still have bogie but I will take it sir!
You ready Wren?
Yeah!
Alright...
Niko for par!
(pain)
OOOOOOH
Oh no!
I'm sorry Wren!
I'm so sorry Wren!
I did not block that in time...
You alright man?
Yeah, dude, I've got the twisting going on right now...
I didn't block it in time!
I saw it coming and I was like: "OH NO!"
I told you I wouldn't miss
I've got good news and I've got bad news...
Good news is that we probably won't hit you in the nuts again
The bad news is, you've got two more shots coming at you
Oh!
Ah
Deh!
God, that stings!
Sorry dude
Oh!
Right on the tailbone!
Good game chaps!
Well, Niko
congratulations
you won the game...
but you still owe me ten dollars
Brett,
Yeah?
We'll practice up and try this again
Sounds good.
Wren, thank you for being a great sport!
And uh, you make a great target!
Let's go stand back in the field...
and Wren gets one shot at each one of us
to try to hit us once
Really!?
Considering there's only one helmet and there's three of us,
I'm feeling pretty good!
Wren if you're gonna aim for me you're gonna have to aim a little better!
Telling you right now!
Aaaah!
Woah!
This also must've been what it was like going into battle...
*thump*
OOOOOH!
Whoo!
I definitely feel bad for Wren...
It sucks being shot at with arrows,
and also for all of our ancestors who got shot at in days of yore
Yeah this video is dedicated to those guys that got killed with arrows
For real!